good morning everyone and welcome to the
house committee on Health and Human
Services and elderly Affairs we have a
couple of hearings scheduled for this
morning and then an executive session
however before we get into any of that
Allegiance I pledge allegiance to the
flag of the United States of America and
to the Republic for which it stands one
nation under God indivisible with
all thank you
everyone uh the first bill under our uh
to be heard this morning is House Bill
1042 and I'll recognize the prime
sponsor representative
roord I pronounce that
correctly okay good I can't always claim
to pronounce things correctly but I'm
glad I did that that's I with a name
like that I've heard all kinds of
iterations so you did good so so yes for
the record my name is David rord I am uh
representative representing Grafton 1 um
I live in Littleton and I'm here today
to uh present to you house bill
1042 and just a couple of background
pieces of information I am a pharmacist
I'm one of two pharmacists in in the
legislature I'm also president of the
New Hampshire Board of Pharmacy um the
Board of Pharmacy actually this the bill
that you have before you is actually has
been requested by the board so I'm
coming here um uh on behalf of them to
talk about
hb142 and uh probably to to to give you
a little background history of 1042 I've
Been On The Board of Pharmacy since 2017
and I'd say it was probably
201 uh um 19 or so that this bill was
put in place
and to give the premise of what the
board of Pharmacy does the Board of
Pharmacy regulates the profession of
Pharmacy on behalf of the citizens of
New Hampshire we we we regulate the
profession of Pharmacy to protect the
public safety of the people of New
Hampshire so back in 2019 very early in
my my my tenure on the board um the idea
of implementing a mandated continuous
quality improvement program um required
by law for pharmac
was was put forward uh this was put
forward by a former board member and a
member of the community and it sounded
great it uh who wouldn't think that
continuous quality improvement would be
a good thing and you know just to
reiterate that's our goal is quality in
Pharmacy it's our goal to to to to
improve and protect safety uh in the
state however as the program has rolled
out and and been
implemented we at theard board have uh
understood that there are many problems
the way the bill is written um the
reality is this is really a best
practices function uh as a as as a
health care professional we're always
looking to improve our our quality we're
all are always looking to improve the
the way we deliver our quality um but
when you stick something in legislature
in black and white in in law that can't
evolve the way a best practices can
evolve and that's what we're finding now
that the law says you have to do
something a certain way but the reality
is we're all doing this in our practice
but we're doing it in the form that fits
best in 2014 2024 not 2019 so the uh the
law is
Antiquated um furthermore it puts it
codifies something again that we are
doing anyway I think there's a lot of
healthc Care Professionals around this
table right now uh there there's not one
of us I venture to say that has not been
involved in a quality related event uh
we're human we we there's there's
there's variables that happen every day
that we can't predict and things happen
but I venture to say that no one has
ever found themselves an a quality
related event and then continued on as
if nothing happened and bowled through
uh that's just not what we do it's not
we as health professionals don't do that
we look to improve we look to to to make
things better but if you look at the law
is
written people partaking in this cqi
program could wait up to three months to
do something about some about a quality
related event so it just doesn't reflect
what's going on in uh in practice um add
this to the fact that the the current
law is very granular it it steps out it
it puts
forward a stepbystep manual on how this
process is supposed to uh take place and
again that is not I think I've
highlighted the point that's just not
practical in today's um delivery of
Pharmacy the reality is Pharmacy in New
Hampshire and and and this is this is
not an extens exhaustive list but we
have Community retail pharmacies which
we all see on every corner we have
Hospital pharmacies we have long-term
care pharmacies we have home infusion
pharmacies we have specialty pharmacies
which was my background we have uh
um nuclear pharmacies we have mail order
pharmacies and we have pharmacies that
are in freestanding emergency rooms
that's just in New Hampshire so to say
one size fits all for a quality
continuous quality improvement uh um uh
program it's just not it's just not
practical um I'm going to coming to the
end of my my discussion here but when
looking at how our profession compares
to others because I as I mentioned we
have nurses we have Physicians around
this table we have EMTs in our in our
legislature and I wanted to see how
Pharmacy compares to other uh
professions as far as safety and quality
improvement
um I counted on the oplc website which
oplc these professions are under uh oplc
21 professions everything from
acupuncture to dentists to nurses to
naturopathic doctors podiatrists even
veterinarians 21 pract professions do
not have something as prescriptive as as
we have in our law um medicine has
something uh it looked like but it
looked like that was more of an
interdisciplinary approach to Quality
whereas this is so going out extending
my search a little bit further I said
well maybe healthc care is not the only
thing that has to do with safety I mean
nobody would want to be in a in a
building that was structurally unsafe so
I looked at Str Engineers electricians
and architext nothing nothing like like
this in their laws
um pharmac y if you added up the rules
and laws in Pharmacy Pharmacy has more
rules and laws than nursing and Medicine
combined and although they're
well-intentioned in this case it gets in
the way we're finding pharmacies that
are you know having to to to to stop
doing what they're doing in order to
comply with the law even though they may
have a better system that their company
provides them but in order to maintain
the the essence of the law they have to
to to interrupt what they're doing
um
I did send a letter around this is from
the Board of Pharmacy kind of highlights
what we have here uh I think there's a
lot of people here that have um you know
will speak either either will speak or
or sign in to support uh and uh oh I
might add when the Board of Pharmacy
originally approached me to do this they
asked me to strike the entire law off
the books and um you know and I and I
believe in that I I I I I don't think we
need that I don't think we need the law
because like I said we're doing it as is
um every practice site is different
they're doing it as it fits their
practice but I did you know make a
compromise because I did want to um um
you know at least recognize the fact
that safety is important I don't think
we need a law to do that so um you know
I I put in that first paragraph to keep
the first paragraph but it was the
board's original intent to strike
everything so if there's any questions
I'd be happy to answer those at this
point representative
McLean thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question um so let's say
that this were to go away um are
pharmacies right now audited by the
board as part of maintaining their
license and do you know if continuous
quality improvement is part of that
audit structure so this log goes away
there's still something in place with
the board that contains a quality
improvement component yeah that's a
that's a good question I appreciate that
question and yes pharmacies in the state
of New Hampshire are are inspected
routinely um and and uh up to depending
on it's risk-based but up to depending
what they're doing twice a year uh
depending on the risk based my Pharmacy
was always visited once a year um um you
know and and I think it's important to
understand how New Hampshire treats that
I've got colleagues in Vermont
Pennsylvania New York that have never
seen an inspector ever once and we're in
our we're in the stores routinely
regularly um and that is part of the the
I'm going to also tell you something too
and
uh reluctant to maybe admit this but I
will so this continuous quality
improvement is part of the inspection so
if you look at the law and I and I the
whole law it's pretty it's pretty bland
it's pretty vanilla so um you know if
there's a mistake the board can't take
that's caught in the cqi program the
board can't uh um uh take an action on
the mistake stake that's in within the
cqi program they're protected from that
you don't want to punish somebody for
for being truthful uh that's our and
that's that's consistent along around
the industry so really what the
inspectors are looking at is are you
doing it and that really is all they
have really to look at is and it have
you have you taken minutes or is there
an agenda um to do that so it's really
do you have a piece of paper that says
you've done it and anybody could reality
is could check off you know a paper that
that that shows compliance and that
really is they could comply with that um
so and and yeah
so that's a two-part of question yes
we're being inspected regularly
routinely more than any other states and
uh they are being checked on that
followup so and just to qu and just to
confirm that that cqi auditing is
happened even before the law so that's
not that's being done by the regulatory
body not by the state State like ISO we
have independent Auditors independent
from the
law so this is something even without
the law this would be happening so even
without the law there are certain
standards that have to be followed is
your you know do you have a clean are
you recordkeeping are you training are
you are you cleaning are you making sure
the drugs are not outdated that you have
on on the on the shelves are the people
who you hire adequately trained and
certified into they meet that yes that's
been going on since the Advent of uh but
this is you know tracking and tracing
and things that uh a little bit but I
want to add most companies if not all
companies have a cqi program outside of
the law that is specific to their
company into their training not only do
companies have it but many insurers
require payers require this as well but
the difference is it's Unique to their
practice setting so you know a CVS to
use their on on the corner is not going
to be required to do sterile compounding
cqi program U because it's not Germaine
to their practice so it's it's the
things that are out there in 2024 are
much better than than than the
law representative
Weber thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question and I'm hoping
for a very short answer to this question
because we're almost behind I'm already
and there other people waiting to talk
but what I want to know it's sort of the
flip side of Representative cl's
question uh you talked about the number
of rules that are promulgated with
respect to pharmacies do you know of any
rules that are operate that are
connected directly to this statute which
might then be rescinded because of the
statute if you know and if that's not
your field that's fine so no it is our
it is we do have so there are rules that
are directly related to this that will
be rescinded to this but there are other
quality related rules that are not
related to this that will remain that's
exactly what I wanted to know thank you
representative Merchant and then
representative Sho thank you Mr chairman
also thank you representative roach for
being here to testify um I would like to
have you look at the letter from the
Board of Pharmacy in bold italics on the
third paragraph furthermore the New
Hampshire Board of Pharmacy has not
documented one case where the say has
improved quality of prevented
errors is that I appreciate you pointing
that out that was on my notes to talk
about and I didn't but absolutely that's
then that's that's the that's the the
Nexus of this is the far Board of
Pharmacy can't prove or show that this
program has improved quality or
prevented errors or or made things more
safe than than than they were prior to
thank you representative Shapiro
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking this question can you for those
of us who are not involved in Pharmacy
can you give an example of a situation
that might arise where this statute
being overly prescriptive caused a
problem yeah I can
so uh a patient comes in for a blood
pressure medicine and it gets filled um
with a blood thinner big problem I mean
huge you know the Physicians here
understand that could be a big problem
or or or so the wrong drug in the wrong
bottle the way the law is written I mean
that that's something that should be
rectified immediately and that's
something that the root cause should be
determined at the moment that it is
discovered as the law is written you
could wait three months to look into
that so I don't think that the the law
is reflective of the practice um so
that's that's that's one of the problems
that we have the other problem that we
have is is you know Define what is a cqi
is it a near miss so so the the drong
got drug got in the bottle but the
pharmacist found it before it went out
is that well obviously that's depending
that it could be it's it's not really
clear in the law of what that you know
is that does that qualify because
clearly the pharmacist did their job and
stopped it but somebody could say well
there was a problem up up above but the
reality is all this we have a duty as a
professional to ensure that mistakes are
fixed and followed up and we have a duty
to to to do quality work um regardless
of what the law says so to make us do
our duty and then follow this rigid
thing that may not be germine to to how
we're going to that's that's why we're
here representative
TZ thank you and uh thank you for taking
my question um in healthc care uh
hospitals and Medical Practice settings
right now CMS is issuing a lot of
mandates that are really incentivizing
or you know creating Behavior change and
practice change as far as um uh the
these kinds of things you know
regulatory things uh is there anything
similar in the pharmacy world that maybe
an accreditor or a funer is uh requiring
quality improvement yes so um CMS you
know Joint Commission you know the the
crediting body
all you in the reality is in order to
get paid now for pharmacy it's becoming
more and more likely you're going to
have to be accredited by somebody um uh
and that's the whole point of
accreditation is quality and and quality
assurance and the benefit of
accreditation is they can move their
standards much more quickly than if you
try to put something in law I mean we
all know that we're always chasing that
as as legislators are always chasing
something the accrediting body that
doesn't have to go through this process
can can move much quicker respond much
more nimbly and do a better job at
addressing really issues in
safety other questions representative
Lon thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for presenting this um if so my question
is in the Remain the part that's
retained it continues to say that this
program is non-ua and seeks to identify
weaknesses and processes and systems um
my question would be if it actually be
more beneficial to repeal thatc the
entire chapter because while the intent
is not to be punitive um doesn't that
tie your hands if there is some Pharmacy
that continues operating and is just
throwing caution to the wind and not
doing it appropriately would it make
more sense to repeal the whole thing
well as I said that was the initial
desire of the Board of Pharmacy is to
real peel the whole thing uh we don't
feel that you know I felt like uh um
going forward I just want to underscore
our point of Pharmacy Board is safety so
I don't want to misre represent or
represent that we are not concerned
about safety however if we repealed
paragraph one I don't think the safety
of New Hampshire would be compromised at
all other
questions I'm seeing none thank you
thank
you also signed up to speak is Kathy
Bizarro thunberg from the new Hospital
minutes good morning Mr chairman and
members of the committee for the record
my name is Kathy bizar thumberg I'm the
Executive Vice President New Hampshire
Hospital Association representing the
state's cute care hospitals and specialy
hospitals in the state I am here today
to testify in support of House Bill 1042
our hospitals take great pride in the
work that they do every day in support
of the patients that they serve part of
that work is continuously reviewing
their quality of care and services
provided and that they are delivered
consistently consistently accurately and
professionally Hospital pharmacies do
utilize continuous quality improvement
or cqi protocols that are integrated
with our Hospital's overall quality
improvement programs we support the
removal of the specific requirements of
Hospital uh Pharmacy specific cqi
program and the reporting of summarized
reports to the Board of
Pharmacy these details of the program
and the statute were redundant and
unnecessary since Hospital pharmacies
already incorporate their work in
hospital operations and overall cqi
programs I would suggest however that if
the first part of the statute remains
that another part of the statute should
also stay in place to ensure sure that
these types of programs remain
confidential and then in my handout in
my testimony I did note um for RSA 318
45a paragraph 6 cqi programs shall be
confidential and continuous quality
improvement records shall be considered
peer-review documents and not subject to
Discovery in civil or administrative
actions the reason for this is because
CQ programs are important because they
promote a culture of openness and Trust
in reporting errors near misses or other
issues with the goal of finding areas of
improvement without fear of reprisal cqi
programs often must include sensitive
information related to Patient Care and
keeping this information confidential is
essential to the privacy and security of
the individual overall C cry programs
focus on Improvement and not blame so
for that um consideration I do wish that
the committee support 1042 with the
consideration of this uh proposed amend
Amendment be happy to answer any
questions okay thank you representative
Weber just to be clear I I understand
your concerns about keeping the
confidentiality issues um am I to
understand from your testimony that you
would be equally okay if we repealed the
whole thing so I did speak to the
sponsor about that um I think it does
make sense that if they do repeal the
entire statute that um we're okay with
that um because Hospital pharmacies as I
mentioned do integrate their cqi
programs within Hospital overall
operations they do also have
confidentiality Provisions there as well
but if we were going to keep something
separate for pharmacy in the pharmacy
statute I think it would have been
appropriate to keep it there as well but
I think we're okay with the overall
repeal and and just as a followup to
that and and the hospitals have
accreditation in programs and and many
compliance overseers Absolut that will
require this is that correct absolutely
thank you representative Leon um thank
you Mr chairman and thank you for
bringing this issue to our attention um
without this law at all is there a
challenge that any um other regulatory
bers bodies the payers the federal
government may try and violate that try
and uh reach through that
confidentiality and would we need to
proactively protect um these programs
whether through this bill or something
else I don't believe so I think we
already have that current
confidentiality in place for other uh
cqi programs so as long as pharmacies
fold in uh with other um existing
programs I think we're okay I will
verify that but I think we're fine thank
you other
questions okay I'm saying none thank you
thank
you no one else has signed up to testify
on
hb142 one person did sign the blue sheet
in the back indicating they were in
favor and um we'll let you know in a
online there were two in support and two
opposed okay with that I am going to
close the public hearing on hb142 and
open the public hearing on HB 106 excuse
me 1609
and I recognize the prime sponsor a
member of our committee here
representative Jim Murphy from Hanover
good morning representative Murphy good
morning Mr chairman and fellow members
of the committee uh and um thank you for
allowing me to introduce this bipartisan
act which is uh relative to the
commission on the primary care Workforce
in the State Office of rural Health um I
believe I gave everybody a copy of my
written testimony so I am not going to
read the entire thing I'll probably try
to summarize um the first page entirely
goes over the um uh alphabet soup word
acronym of all the various entities in
play here uh and I just wanted to try to
Briefly summarize some of the historical
timetable behind each of these uh back
in
2008 the State Office of rural Health s
o r was created it sits under the
section of rural health and primary care
rhpc which is also Al part of
DHHS um the the intent of the um State
Office of rural Health was really to
seek long-term solutions to the
challenge of rural Health Care
particularly in um uh undeserved areas
and with a focus on Primary Care
specifically um subsequently back in
2010 House Bill 1692 then authorized the
S the State Office of rural Health to
create the
uh professional Data Center
hpdc and that was to collect uh data
organizing and regarding the state's
Primary Care
Workforce uh it was with the intent of
not only understanding the primary care
force today uh but also to understand
and try to predict what would be needed
in the future and to basically try to um
um uh serve as a bellweather of what
primary care would look like in the
state particularly in Rural and
undeserved areas
that statute also
created the commission on Primary Care
Workforce uh of which I'm a member and
um uh and it's uh and it's their duty to
basically take the information and try
to understand Primary Care uh in the
state of New Hampshire so if you go to
the bottom of the first page it also
speaks to the oplc I think we all know
that is the office of professional
license insurance certification which uh
was um uh first brought brought onto the
scene about 10 years ago and they
basically provide the administrative
support for over 50 uh Professional
Licensing boards councils and
commissions um they can oplc collects
data regularly um for from the
applicants for these um surveys and for
the lure and is directly uh reports to
representative Murphy could I interrupt
a moment you seem to be microphone sorry
you seem to be referencing your
testimony and I don't have a copy of
your testimony has that been handed out
it was I gave you one handed out
yesterday oh okay sorry I'll give you
one tomorrow I'll give you one I have
another one for you sure I have and if
anybody else does not have what I
thought I gave them to most people as
well so so that's the first page and
it's really the acronyms and all the
historical background to all the
different players um regarding this so
what is why this bill that we need today
first it's to as we regularly do we um
extend the commission so we want to
extend the role of the commission for
Primary Care um Workforce to continue to
do their work it's also to um help oplc
and the um office of um uh rural Health
um share information so that they can
basically dig deep into the into the
information and really understand
through this information what the
primary care Force looks
like
the and why why are we doing this it's
because as we all know Primary Care is
taking a terrible spiral uh throughout
the country and regionally um we have
members in our committee that are in
primary care and I think all of us
recognize that Primary Care is um
really the the number of primary care
providers is dropping off substantially
such that you see regularly articles in
the paper on the news about people that
can't access uh or get access to good
health care because they don't have a
primary care care provider what is your
alternative if they don't have a primary
care provider they can either not get
care we know that's not good or they can
go to emergency room which is very
expensive care and it's usually when
it's um an issue that's failly far down
the
road that doesn't really help with um
the continuity or the quality of
healthare and actually increases
morbidity mortality and cost throughout
the
system why do I care so much about this
because access is such an important part
of healthcare access access to Primary
Care to Specialists to whomever but
access is important access can be
compromised in a number of ways it can
be compromised by a pandemic people just
don't get go to see anybody in
healthcare Health Care can be or access
can be compromised by insurances well
that's another subject altogether but
Primary Care access or the lack of
primary care access is really what we're
talking about today and trying to
understand Primary Care access in the
state is critical itical to
understanding healthare as is delivered
in the state so probably nothing serves
better than a good clinical examples you
know um why is access important if
somebody is having chronic headaches and
they're severe headaches and they don't
seek care they may just have a migraine
or they may just have a headache from
stresses of the day but they also may be
in a hypertensive crisis and what is
that if they're not treated if they
don't go to see somebody if they they
end up in an emergency maybe too late
maybe the only once they stroke or they
have a stroke that they actually do
present so Primary Care access is very
important most of people's interactions
with the healthc care profession are
oftentimes through their primary care
provider um I I don't know the exact
percentage I would anticipate that's a
huge number or a large percentage of
visits um that patients have are to
their Primary Care to get their
medication straightened out to get their
um referrals for uh preventative care so
without Primary Care who's going to make
the referral for their routine mamogram
who's going to determine when their next
colonoscopy is do who's going to do the
paps mere for them who is going to send
them to the dermatologist for a skin
lesion who is going to um do any number
of the preventative Services that we do
blood work for PSA that usually all
centers and comes through the primary
care office if they're not there that is
not getting done and patients are not
being served very
well I had the example or an experience
not quite a while ago now probably about
15 or 20 years ago um a nice man
probably M mid to late 50s comes in with
what he called a
bunch on his thigh I had no idea what a
bunch was and I came to realize the
common vernacular in Northern New
England is a mass I didn't know what
that was I also didn't know what a shock
was a shock is a stroke so there's a lot
of the terminology that I was not aware
of but in any event nice man comes in
with a bunch and he's got a gown on and
I'm looking at his
leg and there is a bunch a mask probably
the size of a cantaloupe or a small
watermelon on his
thigh and my question was how long has
this been here that would be our first
question and I was told it was well over
a year and I said why didn't you see
anybody he says well I don't have
Primary Care
yeah I'm in the rural area of the state
North Country somewhere I don't have any
access to Primary Care and to go to the
hospital would cost me too much money
and really the nearest hospital is 20 30
miles away and I said so what brings you
in today and he says I just couldn't put
my pants on anymore and the the problem
with that is obviously this was
diagnosed well too
late had we seen this person from as a
referral from his primary care provider
provider when it first happened he could
have been
saved um so in any event these are these
are just small not small these are just
a few examples of why Primary Care is so
important Primary Care numbers are
dwindling right now we need to
understand what our primary care for
Workforce looks like we have to try to
anticipate what the f the workforce will
look like in the future the work of the
um um the commission on um uh Primary
Care Workforce working with you know the
oplc gaining the information that's
necessary to understand where these
providers are how old they are when are
they going to retire what is their
specialty are they Internal Medicine
Family Practice Pediatrics OBGYN we need
to understand this if we don't have the
information we can't understand the
practice of primary care in the state
and patients will you know and many of
us who have trouble find finding Primary
Care will not get the care we need in a
timely manner so um there's a lot of
other issues regarding you know um
previous laws and stuff like that and we
have people here that will speak to um
uh exactly what is their needs um but I
would urge us to at least um extend the
commission and allow um information to
be shared with oplc and with the uh
State Office of rural health so that we
can uh better serve our patients and
I'll be happy to take any questions
thank you representative
Weber so basically after all that what
you're asking us to do is simply
continue the work of two bodies that are
already established for another five six
years till 2029 right and so that any of
us who were already concerned as I
suspect we all are about the state of
the primary care Workforce this would be
one way of helping to understand where
we are and where we may need to be in
the future I couldn't have said it any
better okay you know when you think of
it you know if we don't understand our
Primary Care Workforce you know how many
are going to age out in the next five
years how many are going to be coming
into the state how do we not only
understand where we are today where
we're in the future and how do we
encourage Recruitment and retainment of
primary care that's the scope of this
body of this commission thank you Rob
representative Seth King thank you thank
you Mr chair thank you for taking
questions uh could you maybe call my
skepticism a little bit about the
commission um how long has it been
around and what has it really achieved
um and I ask that
because I think we kind of already know
all of us why there's a shortage of
primary care of Physicians I mean who
wants to go hundreds of thousands of
dollar there's less incentive to become
a doctor hundreds of thousands of
dollars in student loan debt you work
terrible hours you're constantly
battling with bureaucracy and Medicaid
and the insurance companies I mean we we
know what the problems are and but we as
legislators clearly aren't fixing it and
we create these commissions I think to
Plate our our guilt and I'm not sure if
they're coming up with any solutions
we're willing to implement so I'm just
I'm not sure what the point is of
keeping something like that going alive
and then also can you explain a little
bit um I'm still not 100% sure what the
um new paragraph is um where it inserts
where it talks about the light what oplc
is going to do are they going to create
new rules and regulations or are they
just giving information that already
exists I'm I'm I'm just a little
confused on that so if you could answer
those two questions multi multiple
questions thank you for the question and
I I would totally agree with you
representative King that it's not that
um your your reference in the the
question is Healthcare broken that's why
we don't have Primary Care Providers
though Primary Care is probably one of
the most gratifying Specialties in all
of medicine they're the ones that
actually make the contact with the
patient they developed the relationships
I was a specialist I had episodic care
yes I had patients that came back for
another broken bone but I didn't see
them on a weekly monthly or yearly basis
like a primary care provider does so
it's an time-honored profession in fact
when those of us that went to medical
school there on the committee would tell
you that back in the day probably the
most revered position in the hospital
was the chief medicine uh or the uh
Chief the chief resident of internal
medicine and that's because they were
probably considered the smartest they
were considered the brightest and so I
don't know if I totally fully understand
all of the the reasons why you know
Primary Care is dwindling I have my
ideas and I would ask others on the
committee they can share it as well is
it a reimbursement you know when we went
to um uh a uh reimbursement model in the
90s where you were paid for procedures
um versus you know time spent quality
time spent with the patient that's when
we saw a number of the uh people going
to the primary care diminish um and it's
difficult to practice rural you know
Primary Care in rural Health settings
when you don't have you know a hospital
setting nearby that you can rely on
comfortably and reliably on a day-to-day
basis there's a lot of issues in primary
care and I would not speak to them only
because I think there's others in our
committee that can do that uh as far as
what has been done with the um um uh the
um uh State Office of um rural Health um
we have them we have representatives
from that office here today they can
actually better than I tell you exactly
what they have done since it started it
was when you asked me before it said
when did it when was it first uh created
that was in 2008 um and so when that was
created in um RSA say 126-a colon 5
that's when it was started in 2008 and
that has been their goal since then for
the past 15 years and it's also in
statute that that has to be re-upped
every four to five years whatever it is
so they can continue the work but I
would bet you and I'll let them speak to
that because they can do that better
than I that their work has been
substantial and if nothing else to
understand why what where we have
deficiencies and gaps in our care that's
critical when you're trying to work with
the federal government
um in trying to recruit people where do
you recruit them what specials do we
need that sort of thing so otherwise
we're working blindly when you don't
understand the demographics of a certain
you know profession like primary care we
don't know where to fill the holes we
don't know how to you know do we need
more Primary Care and Family Practice up
north do we need internal medicine do we
need Pediatrics what is it that we need
what do we need lacking and but I will
let them speak to that one
representative kushman and then
representative pero thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for bringing this
bill um my question is with your
experience on the commission um
specifically talking about gaps in care
um I've had very good experiences with
direct primary care and I I've run into
a lot of people who may not have
insurance or they find their insurance
lacking they don't like the network um
or whatever reasons uh and they need
some semi-urgent care but not enough to
rise the level of going urgent to urgent
care and they can some of these gaps can
be filled in by direct Primary Care
Workforce and I was just wondering what
the general attitude is of the
commission toward um that particular uh
flavor of primary care and if there's
any representation for the direct
Primary Care
um uh providers on the commission great
it's a it's a great question because it
also speaks to the fact that there are
multiple um points of entry into the
Health Care system that if we utilize
them
correctly um it is effective and it's
it's good quality care and it's also you
know cost effective so going to the
emergency room for what you were talking
about is really not cost effective um I
have to admit that I've only been on
this commission for less than six months
I was asked to be on it as the um House
of Representatives uh representative on
the committee but I think the folks
behind me that uh are in the commission
can speak to that better than I uh
specifically regarding that question but
thank you great thank you representative
chaparo thank you Mr chairman um I'm not
sure you can answer this now that I know
you've only been on the commission for
six months but um to piggyback on uh
representative King's question um in in
Keen at chesher Medical Center we now
have a new um Family Medicine Residency
program
um which will
bring um residents to the Keen area to
be trained with the hope that they'll
stick around after they're trained um is
this and I know it's very expensive and
um tremendous amount of work to start
something like this so I'm wondering if
this is the kind of project that
potentially or in fact comes out of um
the commission's
work um one of the the charges of the
commission and the the state office for
Rural health is specifically for
Recruitment and retainment of
professionals um in Rural and in
underserved areas and that's a perfect
example is why that residency I know I'm
familiar with that Family Practice
residency when it was started and that
was exactly the reason we we did that
and the reason that's important and
that's the focus also because that is
also understood when you understand when
you get more information about the the
demographics in the state where are
people coming from where are primary
care doctors coming from well that's a
great resource so what is really notable
is in residency programs in in you know
whether it was in Orthopedics or in
primary
care it's if you train in an area the
likelihood of you staying in that area
is substantially greater so when you
start a you know we had residents that
came from Texas to our Orthopedic
program and they said no way I'll be
here for 4 years get educated and get
out of this God awful you know you know
snow belt up here and half of them if if
not most of them all requested to stay
on staff after they were done and so if
you get them in the door um when you get
them in the door and they see the place
they understand the place that's exactly
what we would be looking at that's
exactly the type of feeder programs that
we need when I was a chief medical
officer at New London Hospital we would
have some of the um um osteopathic
Physicians come over from uh Maine in
their program and I would say one and
two would actually stay and request to
stay on staff after they graduated so
this is exactly what we're trying to do
but we need to understand where these
Avenue where these opportunities are
what are the potential uh inroads to
Primary Care that we can cultivate and
then try to recruit and then M maintain
them in in the practice of primary care
in the state thank you for that
representative
Merchant thank you Mr chairman and also
thank you representative Murphy for
taking my
question given the time you're putting
into the commission can you tell me how
you're compensated is this volunteer
work or is this something that you're
for this is New Hampshire remember that
I that's the point I'm trying to make I
I have so I will say that since I
retired from my practice having been on
Hospital boards fiscal policy boards um
in the House of Representatives and on
this commission I have not generated a
W2 form at all I get paid well we all
get paid what we get paid for the house
for the house beyond that I do not get
any extra pay for this commission at all
um but I'm happy to serve on it because
frankly access to Primary Care is one of
my passions despite being a specialist
it is one of my
passions thank you representative navel
thank you Mr chairman this is really
more of a comment and since we've gone
down into levity um I would ask that we
put into permanent record the comment
that a surgeon stated very publicly that
the smartest person in the hospital is
the chief resident in Internal
Medicine would you not agree with me I
totally other
questions representative
Palmer um
so obviously this this is near and dear
to my heart because um I'm working a lot
more this year because there aren't
enough people coming in um but the
pipeline is is important and I'm asking
this now and other people hopefully will
comment on this is we have one medical
school in in New Hampshire there are a
couple of there a couple of residency
programs that have started the one in
Keane there's one in oh shoot Portsmouth
um which is great great but we have one
medical school which is a private
medical school and it it's expensive and
um a lot of the people that go to that
medical school are planning to go into
Specialties and not necessarily focus on
um primary
care um is the commission looking at all
at trying to figure out how to get you
know another medical school or medical
students here because that well thank
you for that question and I I'm totally
uh sympathetic and empathetic with with
that um question and that concern um the
short answer is no I for my
understanding uh again I'm a six-month
veteran on the service here um without
pay but having said that I think that
the primary focus is to to understand
the the the the gaps in health care and
Primary Care in the state where they
exist what Specialties exist in Primary
Care being you know multiple Specialties
as you know um and then how to uh
recruit and retain if they are doing
work on trying to build another Medical
School here in the state I'm not aware
of it if they're if if we're working to
try to incentivize medical students to
go into Primary Care in some way or
another I'm not aware of it though that
would certainly be an offshoot and I can
let them speak to that as far as the
Recruitment and retaining um but
um as as those have been here for a
while in medicine understand the the mid
90s when we instituted what they call an
rvu a relative value unit for
reimbursement that dramatically changed
the landscape of uh healthc care and the
professions that people went into so
that proceduralist were getting paid
more but the people that spend more
quality time like Dr Palmer with
patients daytoday were were not being
reimbursed adequately enough I think
that's beyond the scope of the
commission though we can actually try to
recognize it as a concern and try to
then promotee through the legislature
potentially you know programs that would
um en enhance Recruitment and retainment
of of um primary care providers but
thank you other
you also signed up to speak Danielle
hernandz and John Williams attorneys
with the Department of Health and Human
Services and you've asked for less than
good morning chairman McDonald and
members of the Health Human Services L
Affairs committee for the record I am
John Williams I am the director of
legislative affairs for the New
Hampshire Department of Health and
services and thank you for this
opportunity to come for you today uh on
HB 1609 and with me is Daniel Hernandez
I'm the administrator of uh the Health
Professions data center or hbdc which
exist under the State Office of rural
health or the sore we love our acronyms
at uh
HHS and we we are here in support of the
entirety of the bill but specifically
want to thank the commission because
part of their charge also includes the
collaboration between our agency and
Miss Hernandez and and her crew at the
State Office of rural health and keeping
to the three minute time limit I just
wanted to let you know the good works we
did on section three of the bill
starting on lines 13 uh through the
remainder down to 18 prior to the enact
the effective date so um we have a very
good collaborative relationship with the
office of professional Li Insurance
certification and we have under our
statute under RSA
126-a colon 5 Roman 18 lower
case-a the ability to receive and to
collect certain information that is
helpful to us to provide uh information
to the commission to the legislature as
it relates to the licensed individuals
whether they're dentist whether they're
doctors and a whole salute that you'll
see in our enabling legislation for uh
targeting the information uh for those
folks I just want to remind it is a
voluntary uh uh process there is an opt
out provision we have the wonderful um
Prime sponsor again I can't believe it
today is deja vu from uh from represent
Lori Harding who's in the audience who
actually helped and worked
collaboratively with Senator Carson at
the time around very thoughtful
provisions and legislation so we're
entering into what they call a memor
random of agreement with our other
agency working collaboratively with the
office of professional licensure and
certification and they very thoughtfully
identified that we and the department
already have this Authority and have
been exercising it and we've been
protecting data and we've been giving
good information but they identified and
you'll see on line um 14 of the bill
that it amends RSA uh
3105 that essentially is their enabling
legislation for their Authority for
doing certain things and so this would
be an additional item to mirror to
provide them with the same reciprocal
Authority uh in a cross cross references
back specifically to the RSA that I
quoted and because of three minutes I
won't quote it again uh but it is in the
bill itself um and that is exactly what
we're we're doing so this language was
worked on in collaboration of both
agencies and we're here today to
represent that it's a wonderful thing
putting belts and suspenders and to
include in their their um provision of
law that reciprocal Authority so with
that I do know we have a brief amount of
time so I do want to turn it over to
Miss Hernandez because she really has a
volume of information in terms of the
Merit and the um work that's been done
not only by the commission but
specifically by the State Office of
rural Health which she serves in that
capacity does a wonderful job and also
to respond to various questions by the
committee members that have been raised
so with that I'll turn it over to Miss
Hernandez and then to questions from the
committee reveres McDonald thank you so
much thank you so hbdc the Health
Professions data center was developing
under the sword to receive available
data as John had said and collect data
through provider surveying during
license renewal to assess the current
and anticipated um primary care
landscape in New Hampshire this
initiative was codified in 2019 with the
requirement for hpdc to report to HHS
oversight and uh to inform the work of
the legislative Commission on the
interdisciplinary Primary Care Workforce
so this data really has significant
impact and value it helps to support and
strengthen Federal shortage designation
uh performed by our office which brings
Primary Care Providers and grant funding
to Rural and underserved areas of the
state it supports Recruitment and
Retention initiatives including among
others the state loan repayment program
and New Hampshire recruitment center it
supports the development and expansion
of existing um educational and
employment training programs most recent
L coas County's Family Medicine
Residency in Berlin um and as was
mentioned earlier cheshire's Family
Medicine Residency in keen and of course
it supports and strengthens emergency
preparedness so oplc collects and
maintains a number of Licensing Fields
fundamental to provider surveying
shortage designation and Workforce
assessment without access to these
fields hpdc effectively loses its
ability to fulfill our statutory and
Federal Grant
requirements we have been receiving this
data through a data sharing agreement
until August 2023 just recently when it
was determined by oplc that they would
need the statutory authority to share
data um and this bill does exactly that
right it grants statutory authority to
oplc to share Workforce uh data related
fields with the sore which already has
uh the statutory authority to receive it
effectively just closing a legisl
discrepancy all but one licensing field
is public data the one non-public data
field provider email is essential and
used for provider uh compliance followup
to increase response rates so um as is
the case with all lure requirements the
survey requirement is verified through
provider attestation on the licensed
renewal form unfortunately we still see
even three years after the survey was
implemented as a condition of renewal uh
non-compliance rates between 15 and
25% when our program hpdc sends out that
uh reminder email to Providers it's
reduced to about 1 to 4% so without our
hand in the compliance office what would
happen is the final non-compliance uh
list sent to opl's enforcement division
would increase significantly and we risk
losing reliable representative data that
can only come with higher responses um
and is also you know critical and
necessary for shortage designation work
and uh provider to population analysis
to determine need we could start
wrapping up please yep um and that's
really it just to continue this valuable
work uh around Workforce and and to
inform policy we DHHS is in support of
HB
1609 thank you representative kushman
thank you Mr chairman and thank you um
for speaking um to how you see this bill
um Bill's value um I am wondering you
mentioned a voluntary process for opt
out of something or actually it was um
Mr Williams I believe can you I I didn't
catch what exactly you were uh
referencing so when the survey was
implemented as a condition of renewal we
wanted to ensure that you know uh
quality practicing clinicians weren't at
risk of losing their license based on a
survey and so it was important to us to
also Implement um uh the completion of
either the survey or the opt out form
they exist on the same page on DHHS and
and providers can certainly choose the
opt out form to say you know this is my
name like minimum data points for
shortage designation use name uh
specialty um if they practice in New
Hampshire um and that fulfills the
requirement H
up okay um thank you that is very
helpful um so now I'm just trying to
weigh that against what you said about
um you know you're you're chasing after
compliance so you need their email
address because you you need those
answers and when you were saying that it
was interesting to me because I didn't
know that there was this opt out because
as a nurse I have to fill out the survey
during my renewal process on the oplc
website every two years before I can
even finish it so um I'm just trying to
kind of square that how you know where
we have the opt out but now we're kind
of um want to make it that it's
involuntary or that there's more
pressure more ability for there to be
more pressure to fill out the survey for
lack of a better phrasing sorry for
clarity uh the compliance follow-up is
for providers to complete either the
survey or the opt out form and that's
made clear in the email Communications
out other
questions representative L on um thank
you Mr chairman it sounds like the Board
of Nursing has a more streamlined
process through the oplc do you know if
all the other relevant licensing boards
are moving to that same process where we
won't have that same compliance because
you can't complete it without the optin
or the survey going forward the way the
survey is implemented um for all
participating provider types is uh
consistent so every yep clinician that
participates under their respective
boards has the opportunity to complete
either the survey or the opt out form
and it was a recent move in The Last 5
Years that um all Health Professions
boards have um have transitioned from
paper renewals to online renewals just
to streamline that process thank you
representative palazov thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
so without this commission are there
other ways to get a federal shortage
designation and receive uh the
I'm sorry can you repeat like uh if not
for this commission are there other ways
to receive federal shortage
designation what the commission has done
for um this portion of the work is um it
was really through the commission
through recommendations that the St
Source Health Professions data center
was established through legislation so
that's really um and through that
legislation we also have the rec
reporting requirement to inform their
work which we do throughout the
year other
questions seeing none okay thank you
you also signed up to speak is Christine
starded from the by state Primary Care
minutes good morning thank you um as the
chairman noted my name is Christine
Stoddard and I am the director of public
policy at bate Primary Care Association
and I'll try and do my best to answer
some of the questions that were asked
that relate to our community health
centers so by state is an advocacy
organization that works to expand
Primary Care access to all New Hampshire
residents including in uh the districts
that you serve we also represent
community health centers including
federally qualified Health Centers which
can only be established in the country
using the data that is collected by um
departments like and divisions like the
sore we could not Access Federal
programming without the data that their
organization
collects in 2022 our community health
centers um served or had over 48,000
visits so these are primary care visits
that include substance use disorder
treatment we use a very Broad broad
definition of primary care substance use
disorder treatment oral health services
um what you would typically think of
when you think of primary and preventive
care including reproductive Health Care
Services we rely on the data that is
collected by SAR and the conversations
that happen at the commission to
Advocate at the federal level for
funding that directly benefits your
constituents and the districts that you
serve and um representative Seth King to
answer one of your questions that you
asked there are community health centers
that serve your district there are four
clinicians benefiting from the state
loaner payment program in your your
District alone and um they wouldn't be
able to do that if we didn't have the
information collected by sore and the
work of the commission so it is very
important we do support house bill 16009
because of its work and I can't
overstate the importance of the
commission it did help as Danielle noted
um us to establish estblished a teaching
Health Center residency program at Coos
County family health services and that
was done in partnership with un and gel
school of medicine they are also
partnering with the hospitals in their
area to ensure that the four residents
that they plan on bringing in 2025 can
serve the North Country in a a
culturally appropriate way and we do our
best to retain those residents once they
complete their Residency program uh just
the fqhcs alone have 131 vacancies
and and that's 10
organizations so being able to access
the data that SAR collects and as I
noted the work of the commission is very
important to our ability to decrease
those vacancies and also recruit and
retain additional clinicians um
throughout the
state I think most other um speakers
have have answered a number of your
questions that you've had so I'm happy
to answer any more if you have them but
um I know you're already backed up so
thank you uh representative N
upam I didn't listen quick enough thank
you for taking my question um you have
131 vacancies in New Hampshire for
doctors no that actually runs the gamut
so that includes front desk staff Mas
RNs
aprns um MDS and Do's it's across the um
Health Center um Workforce is it
possible to see a breakdown of those
numbers be happy to get that sure I'd be
happy to get that to you okay thank you
questions okay anyone else I'm seeing no
you also signed up to speak is Mary bidg
good
minutes I think I can do it in less than
that you have my written um testimony
and so instead of highlighting points
from that I just wanted to answer some
questions I'm a family nurse
practitioner and a certified nurse
Midwife I've practiced in New Hampshire
for about 40 years in The Lakes Region
and um I'm the chair of the legislative
commission so the commission was
established in 2010 was someone's
question um in response to your question
about direct Primary Care um we have had
a short presentation regarding it and
one of the direct primary care nurse
participants in the state is now
attending the meetings as a guest and
hoping
to uh make that more broadly integrated
into our interdisciplinary committee we
worked um very closely with un over the
last five to six years two of their
faculty members are now um guests almost
every month at our meetings and we've
established clinical rotations for those
medical students in New Hampshire again
underscoring if you train them here
they'll stay here um we worked very hard
in the to De development of the three
residency programs the North Country
which is unique in that it is a rural
Residency program and then the first
class that's graduating from Portsmith
this year they graduated in July and
then the first class that will be
starting in chesher um this June and um
we worked uh very hard with the a new
project UNH which um is for advanced
practice registered nurses and the
statistics there are about 85% of them
stay in state um after graduating from
the program and we worked um with
helping to validate and extend the ahac
federal program so I think those were
most of the questions that I
heard thank you any
questions representative kushman thank
you Mr chairman and thank you just a
quick question thank you for answering
that question about the direct Primary
Care it sounds like they they are kind
of able to come and and have the
conversation but do you think it would
be appropriate to put in an amendment
since they are an expanding um branch of
the primary care Workforce to add a
position for a representative of that
particular brand of Provider yes we try
to really be very inclusive and very
interdisciplinary and it um I did a
short presentation on this last fall and
many people think it is the wave of the
future that people especially with the
huge deductibles that people have that
um it is it for healthy young families
it is a way for them to access Primary
Care in a affordable but very um
comprehensive
way other questions representative TZ I
have a question actually it's followup
to your question so um would you say the
membership is employers or sort of um
representatives of disciplines and then
to follow on if you were to have um uh
like what would you call the category of
of entities that uh what is it prob
direct MD or whatever she called it the
um direct primary care direct Primary
Care would be yeah um I don't know if
they have a official group that meets or
not I guess I would need to explore that
um but certainly having them come as a
guest has been valuable um the rest of
the commission you know what kind of
runs the gamut from the New Hampshire
Medical Society the nurse practitioner
Society to UNH um guel School of
Medicine um by state
um there's a listing of all the
testimony other
questions say no other questions thank
you you
welcome no one else has signed up to
1609 uh on the blue sheet in the back
three people did sign up in favor of uh
hb1 1609 and online online there were 33
signed in in support and one
opposed with that I am I'm going to
close the public hearing on hb1 169
those are the only hearings we have
scheduled for today we're going to take
a brief break of maybe 10 minutes 10
minutes and uh then we we convene and
session and Mr chair you're planning to
end by 12 is that correct yeah because
we
have we have an an ongoing obligation at
[Music]
absolutely I like how and the other
thing I was going to ask was want me to
gra the other one support for repealing
the autism registry because it seems to
me that once you deal with all the
things that can be
withdrawn the data is no longer good
data and the only person who supported
keeping it was great Ms who established
some would like
to
theice
don't
want
that
Amendment people could start taking
seats
please is everyone here I think so I
don't see any representative McKay is
coming but you're coming that's the
important thing okay okay I'd like to
convene the executive session we we have
uh 35 minutes before the caucuses both
parties caucuses begin across the street
so uh in the interest of time we need to
we need to get started um change the
order around a little bit we have four
bills to ex U consider an executive
session today uh we'll get as many done
as possible starting off with hb1 1604
FN uh representative Nagel I believe you
thank you Mr chairman I would like to
move um aop pass Amendment
28h and that's coming around now I trust
HB
1604 okay is there a second to that
motion second representative Merchant
seconds would you like to speak to your
motion representative n um in response
to our very um wonderful discussion
yesterday basically all this does is it
changes what was line8 in the original
bill it's now line three in the
amendment um to basically limiting this
provision to any health carrier um that
operates in the state of New Hampshire
not any federal um insures so in other
words it doesn't apply to Medicare
Medicaid which we knew going into this
um now we're putting it in writing um
there were concerns um from another of a
number of stakeholders that that might
be a problem we believe that this line
fixes that okay other than that it's the
same bill anyone else wish to speak to
this
amendment representative kofalt then
representative Weber uh yes thank you Mr
chairman uh so I just want to make sure
that I understand clearly um based on
what I see in line one this would
effectively delete section three from
the original Bill thank you yes and that
that was part of
oops top down yeah that was our
discussion yesterday as well I mean I I
I'm not in my world it's not ideal but
that's a a fight for another day okay
representative
Weber and following on to representative
kof's question I just the amendment we
had yesterday would have deleted three
in its entirety is that right okay so we
were referring to section three
yesterday not one or two one or two
stand this is the replacement
thank
you on the original bill um um the first
um section one which just defines
electronic medical record that still
exists section two is changed as is here
section three is eliminated and um the
last two effective dates still
present got you should all make sure I'm
correct on that because when I got this
it confused me to death um other
questions and and and if I'm following
on yeah and this does because it says
amend two and three is inserted by
section one of the bill by replacing it
with the following so three is gone two
is amended one is still the same and yes
we're all good thank you thanks other
questions other discussion seeing none
so the motion is ought to pass on
Amendment 2024 hyen 0728 H I'll ask that
representative Lon yes representative
kushman yes representative Bill King yes
representative kofalt yes representative
mlan
yes representative Seth King
yes representative Missour yes
representative Nagel yes representative
peloso
yes representative Weber yes
representative McKay
yes representative fedus yes
representative Canon
yes representative Nutter upam
yes representative Shapiro
yes representative Merchant
yes representative Murphy yes
representative Palmer yes representative
tus
yes representative M um McDonald yes
20 to zero okay thank you representative
Nagel do you wish to make another motion
I'd like to make a motion a to pass um
house bill 16004 as amended by Amendment
20247 28h second motion has been
seconded by representative Merchant is
there any further discussion on this
representative King Seth King thank you
Mr chair uh I'm not going to spend too
much time on this um I am opposing the
bill as amended um I agree with the
general sentiment of not liking the
electronic medical records
um I don't you can see here I don't have
a computer I like to keep my paper
records and and I definitely think that
um there there have been a lot of
problems with electronic medical records
that's that's a given um however
generally speaking as I've mentioned
times in the past if there's some sort
of problem in the code that's
incentivizing Health carriers to require
it because maybe they have to meet
deadlines or something then we should
look to remove that code I don't really
like adding new code um generally
speaking I I do believe that most
problems we experience in society are
government caused and we should be
looking to remove that cause not adding
new lines of code that's going to take
away Freedom even more so a bill like
this sort of presumes
to it presumes that there's never any
conceivable reason why a health provider
would or yeah a health carrier would
would would really need EMR and and I
don't believe that I think that um you
know in a free market system competition
would dictate what what is really
demanded and there might be some there
might be some who some healthc care
carriers who um you know they they
totally um um work towards helping
people stick to you know paper Rec
records and then there might be others
that um are really geared towards people
that are perfectly happy with um with
electronic medical records and you know
if if we had a bill like this in there
then they wouldn't be able to just serve
that clientele so I I don't like the
one-size fits-all approach overall it's
not the end of the world but it's just
another one of these little bits of code
that just makes it a little bit more
difficult to comply and it it it makes
the whole process just a little bit more
sclerotic and I just prefer competition
and letting the market decide which is
best I'm old school I like my paper too
and I definitely see there's been a lot
of problems but I I'm not ready to ban
it completely so that's why I oppose it
thank
you representative L did you have your
hand up sure um thank you Mr chairman um
to me I just see this as something
that's empowering doctors who don't want
to have a electronic medical record to
do so um that's why I'm supporting it
but um I I understand sometimes we look
at the same bill and see it from
different perspectives and I absolutely
understand that and respect that opinion
but I just wanted to say I think that
this provides the doctors more more
choice and I I think that uh I think we
probably all know where we stand on this
one but I thank you for sharing that
other
discussion seeing none I'll ask the
clerk to call the role the motion is
ought to pass as amended on hb1 1604
FN
representative Lan yes representative
kushman yes representative Bill King yes
representative kofalt yes representative
uh mlan yes representative Seth King no
representative Missour yes
representative
Nagel representative pelosa
yes representative Weber yes represent
McKay
yes representative fedus
yes representative Canon
yes representative nut upam
yes representative Shapiro
yes representative Merchant
yes representative
Murphy yes representative Palmer
yes representative tez
yes and representative McDonald
yes 19
to1 you know that can't be on consent
because it's got a fiscal note
representative we is that
correct I believe it has a fiscal note
but it has no appropriation in it so
because it has no appropriation it need
not go it's and it's it's not going to
finance so I I think it's okay there's
no objection then we'll put that on the
consent calendar I'm sure that the
upstairs review will let us know if
we've done that wrong
sure and representative Nagel if you can
get that report to me sometime this
afternoon I thank you everyone by the
way for getting the reports to me
yesterday so so timely and I did have
forwarded them on to the committee
Services folks and and I really
appreciate
that no Minority Report I I assume
representative
King do I have to write one no you don't
I don't care to no okay all right uh
then we're jumping around a little bit
more uh we're going to go to hb6 60 FN
next do I have a
motion Mr chair I move a to pass
motion's been made ought to pass on 1660
FN is there a second representative
kushman seconds would you like to speak
to your motion representative
kofalt uh yes I'll be quick uh as I said
um gender reassignment surgery for
minors is um is something that many
taxpayers think is um is a bad idea it
is medically not necessary and um we
ought not to be covering it with
Weber you just shut your mic off by the
way sorry thank you um and I would just
say that I take the opposite position I
believe that um first of all these
surgeries are necessary and life saving
I also believe that they're very rare uh
but this bill is more far-reaching than
the bill we already passed which was a
ban so it has the potential in the case
of the surgery still covered by it of
creating a two-tiered s um two- tiered
um standard of care and treatment and I
think that that we have recognized in
other cases that that's inappropriate so
um for those reasons I will be voting
against the octopath and hoping for a
different motion okay other discussion
representative
um I'm not comfortable with um miners
having these kind of surgeries whether
it's bottom surgery or Top surgery and
if it was someone who was in my circle
in my life and my family I would try to
encourage them to do everything I could
to wait until they were older to make a
um some of us might have noticed that
there were about 20 bills limiting what
transgender people can do or can't do
and we're not talking about other kinds
of surgeries that are
um that miners have and so I just think
that this is discriminatory and so I
will vote against it because don't want
to discriminate against transgender
people okay thank you representative
Leon and then representative kof um
thank you Mr chairman um I am not aware
of Medicaid covering uh breast surgeries
for minors unless there's a malignancy
or um that they're so heavy that there's
back problems if there is in fact a
disparity between this be where um where
transgender CH transgender children
wouldn't be able to have a Top surgery
that would be paid for as an augment
ation or removal for somebody who's not
transgender um I hope that you would all
co-sponsor a bill with me next year in
order to remove that Medicaid funding uh
for anything other than a malignancy
something that's back pain let's figure
out where are those ones where any any
child can't wait until they're 18 for
that for payment and um make sure that
there is actually a true equity on this
but um as far as I'm I I don't know that
we cover that for any anybody other than
potentially transgender children
representative kofalt
thank you Mr chair so with respect to
the uh concern expressed about a
two-tier system um I will read from the
healthcare.gov website many health plans
are using exclusions such as Services
related to sex change um so there is not
a uh single uh standard across the board
for uh private insurance either um and I
would assert that this does not create a
two-tiered system in which Medicaid
recipients don't have access to
something that every everybody else does
have access to okay thank you other
discussion representative Shapero and
then representative
Canon thank you Mr chair I just want to
respond to representative Leon um and
because I research this with um
Department of Medicaid um you are
accurate that um breast augmentation and
breast
reduction and um limb lengthening and
those jobs are not covered if they're
purely cosmetic so I just want to say
that that is accurate I still think that
the reason that we're constantly talking
about what transgender people can or
can't do or what can be reimbursed and
what can't be
reimbursed in my mind is because we are
discriminating against one particular
group of people and I don't want to be
doing that just response and was
directing that towards me all right very
quick um thank you um I I take issue
with you saying that it's discriminatory
I think that um I think that treating
children equally that there's certain
medical procedures that simply aren't
available to you reach a certain age
should be the same for all children and
I think that it sets a false expectation
of these surgeries being available I
view this out of compassion because it
sucks to be a teenager for everybody um
let's let's focus on the fact that being
a teenager is really really hard and
support people while not necessarily
making it uh making it seem like early
surgery is the solution to problems
because it's only one factor there we
have to look at the whole child not just
the part that involves a scalpel
representative Canon and then
representative
Murphy if I understand our
responsibility as a legislature is uh
that we're here to protect the the
public and our constituents from uh uh
problems um and
um our charges to put controls in place
where none exist uh I contend in in this
situation there are um in the medical
field there are controls and that part
of that is from the world professional
association for transgender Health um
they don't recommend surgery for anyone
under the age of 18 and they would
rather that people get to the age to uh
of consent of of uh of adults over the
age of 18 um that said um I did some
investigation on my own and the National
Institute for held did uh uh a study it
it uh it dates back from uh 2013 to 2020
they uh identified 209 surgeries that
were done uh out of that uh breast
surgeries no genital surgeries the um uh
out of that they uh identified one
complication and two were post operative
regret and neither of those people went
um uh un underwent reversal surgery so
in those cases um there was there was no
Pro no problem that we would have to
deal with that this legislation would
catch so I I believe that this
legislation only puts um government in
the way of of the general public and I
don't believe it's
needed thank you representative Murphy
thank you I'll be brief and I I suspect
we all know where this is going to fall
out in in the vote but I just wanted to
make a a couple two very um small points
basically um this is amazing to me that
this is a procedure that gets probably
more pre-operative evaluation than any
elective procedure I know about so
number one I think it's done with
thoughtful care for the patient and
those in need for it um and number two
um I was asking um in when this was
presented by uh representative kofalt uh
um week or two ago does this include all
surgeries and he said yes I talked to
the folks at DH and um they
categorically told me that they do not
do these surgeries at DH so um I I think
it's important to understand that
there's sometimes misinformation about
what is done and what is not done and
they categorically as a tertiary care
quary care referral center do not do
these procedures thank you thank you
other discussion representative Missour
yes thank you Mr chair I also sorry
respectfully take offense to these bills
being called discriminatory
because the
words it was said that we are not
talking about that we're talking about
trans people but this bill is specific
to children and we are talking about
irreversible procedures on children so
this isn't a discriminatory bill on
trans people this is a bill protecting
children from things that can't be
undone so so that's my statement on that
other
discussion saying none okay the motion
is ought to pass on hb1 1660
FN ask collect to call the
r representative Lon yes representative
kushman yes representative Bill King yes
representative kofalt yes representative
mlan
yes representative Seth King yes yes
representative Missour yes
representative Nagel
yes representative POF
yes representative Weber no
representative McKay no Representative
fedus
no representative Canon
no representative Nutter
upam representative Shapiro
no representative Merchant no
representative Murphy
no representative Palmer no
Representative tez no and represent
McDonald yes 10 to 10 as as was
motion representative
Weber I was so hoping that somebody else
would put their hand up but I move itl
representative re moves itl is there a
Canon is there any other discussion on
this suspect we've kind of talked it out
uh so when the clerk is ready uh
representative TZ yeah I um I I just
want to follow on with what
representative Murphy said that uh in
fact we have no evidence that this is
happening in children and the only place
that does it in New Hampshire says they
do not do it it's on their website and
uh representative Murphy followed that
up with with his own inquiry um and then
I would say I think it's discriminatory
to not provide equal coverage uh to
people who may happen to be on Medicaid
for whatever reason that's a um you know
many people can end up on Medicaid for
very different reasons in their life and
we should not be uh creating barriers
for people who may be experiencing
harder times at a certain point in their
life um so that would be my
add-on okay thank you other discussion
on motion representative
kushman thank you Mr chairman um to that
discussion about Dartmouth Hitchcock um
respectfully we did hear from them here
in the committee and they did not say
that it never happens they said it's
rare and I'd be interested to know if
they would you know State on the record
in a legislative hearing that no it's
never happened and additionally I
requested their policies and procedures
and the um body of uh medical literature
that they rely on for performing such
procedures um and they sent me back
two um surveys Behavioral Science
surveys um that talked about suicide
ideation before and after hormones um
so I with that I I'm going to
respectfully say that I don't have much
confidence that this expert organization
is providing us a full picture of what's
going on with these surgeries and um
they have not demonstrated that there's
clear uh scientific body of evidence
that they're relying for them so um and
the main point that I feel for this bill
is that it's inappropriate for taxpayers
to be paying for elective surgeries like
this so thank
you any other
discussion seeing none I'll ask the
clerk to call the all the motion is itl
on HB 1660
FN representative Lon no Representative
kushman no representative Bill King no
Representative kofalt no Representative
mlan
no representative Seth King no
representative Missour
no representative Nagel
no representative Palo no
representative Weber yes representative
McKay yes representative fedus yes
represent Canon yes represent
rupam representative Shapiro yes
representative
Merchant
yes representative Murphy
yes representative Palmer yes
representative TZ yes
and representative McDonald
no 10 to
10 okay so that'll go uh in the calendar
without a recommendation uh
representative kofalt and representative
Weber you'll get those reports to me
this afternoon thank you it is now 10
minutes of noon uh I know there's some
interest in doing a little more work on
the other two bills uh from yesterday so
we'll continue HB 1683 and HB
1568 uh to next week uh it'll be quite a
quite a session next Wednesday for
executive sessions but um we don't have
any hearings that day I don't we have
too oh we do okay so it'll be a full day
but uh we'll make the most of it so with
that uh I'm going to call I'm going to
adjourn this meeting and I know we both
have Co both parties have caucuses uh in
adjourned